yes finally apple is doing it they're
giving us a 14 inch ipad after so many
years of people asking for a larger ipad
than the 12.9 inch we're finally getting
the 14 inch and it is confirmed by the
most reliable apple analyst in terms of
display leaks ross young and in this
video we actually have some exclusive
leaks and information that he has been
giving to us through his super follower
program on twitter so with that said
let's jump into this new 14-inch ipad
because i actually have three different
scenarios for what this 14-inch could
actually turn out to be so i'll be going
through those three in this video so
let's get started last week we got a
really surprising leak from imagineboo
saying that his sources are talking
about apple developing a 14.1 inch ipad
m2 with 512 gigs of storage and 16 gigs
of ram saying that it's gonna be
alongside the 11 inch model and a new
12.9 inch model saying that we could get
it in october or in november now at
first this seemed kind of sketchy and
hard to believe but guess what happened
the very next day ross young came out
and confirmed that yes apple is working
on a 14.1 inch ipad pro and first he
said it's going to have mini leds and
promotions saying that it could be
coming in early 2023 so ross young
actually confirmed imagine boo's leak
and making it even better mark german
came out and quote tweeted ross young's
leak confirming that yes apple is
working on a larger ipad so that's very
nice to see because mark german is one
of the most reliable apple analysts of
all time has been around for many many
years but unfortunately we have some bad
news that ross young gave us but before
i get into that news i want to show you
guys what a 14-inch ipad could
potentially look like if you're trying
to figure out what it could be well
right here we have the 11-inch ipad air
for example and this is the huge
inch ipad model whatever it's going to
be this is how big this one's going to
be and look at that that is a massive
difference in terms of the actual screen
real estate and just
massive it's crazy to believe and here's
the shot from the back it's a lot bigger
i can imagine this is going to be quite
heavy so you'll probably need a keyboard
case but let's get into that new leak
from ross young he ended up confirming
with his sources that know promotion is
unlikely to come to this new 14
inch ipad not only that but it's also
not going to be getting mini led as well
so basically those are the two things
that make an ipad pro an ipad pro so
because of that he's saying that it's
likely that this is probably just some
kind of other ipad and thankfully i am
super following ross young on twitter
which is five bucks a month but it's
worth it because his exclusive tweets
that he said about that 14 inch it's
very very interesting but first i want
to point out that right now in 2022 ross
young is literally the most
accurate apple leaker out there 92.9
accuracy and interestingly the only
thing he got wrong was that he said the
iphone se3 will be called the se plus 5g
so he just got the name wrong and that
was probably one of his guesses or
something from a source but in terms of
the actual details of displays he's been
nailing the display sizes including the
macbook pros the ipad mini 6 and the
macbook air which is 13.6 inches so i
ended up replying to a super tweet where
he said that the 14 inch ipad is not
going to be an ipad pro model and that
it's going to be coming in the first
quarter of 2023 and i asked him about
another scenario that i have is there a
chance it's some sort of tablet that's
meant to be used for the smart home or
something else maybe like for a
potential homepod slash display combo
and he said there is always a chance
however in terms of ipads it gives apple
a way to upsell the 10.2 inch ipad
customers to a 14 inch display panel
because the panel prices are really
cheap and they're getting cheaper so it
won't cost much more than the 10.2 inch
and at that point i said hey what if
it's basically a 14.1 inch ipad max for
450 to 550 and he actually agreed that
it could be a possibility but getting
back to that smart home tablet idea ed
hardy who is also a super follower
mentioned the theory saying could this
be the rumored combination homepod slash
apple tv slash facetime camera product
from apple with a built-in screen just
for video calls and i said yes that's
what i am wondering as well because if
we go back we can see that march 22nd of
2021 apple was developing a new homepod
model or multiple models with screens
and cameras so what if they take a 14
inch ipad display kind of tablet and
combine it with this hub that also has a
home pod built in where you stick it
into your kitchen and it uses center
stage to track you around your kitchen
as you're chatting with someone on
facetime not only that but makeshifko
came out just last month saying that
apple is going to be releasing a new
homepod in late 2022 or early 2023 which
actually matches up to ross young's date
for the 14 inch ipad so what if this is
actually the new hybrid homepod slash
tablet screen device but unfortunately
ross young is pretty clear that he
believes it is actually gonna be an ipad
and he mentioned it multiple times
throughout multiple super tweets that he
was putting out so i don't think it's
gonna be that new tablet with home hub
product from apple but now moving away
from that idea we gotta try to make
sense of this 14-inch ipad because ross
young was saying it's not gonna have
promotion and it's not gonna have mini
led which likely means it's not going to
be an ipad pro so why would apple create
this new product with a larger display
than the current 12.9 inch ipad pro and
not have it be a pro model it doesn't
make any sense just like steven warwick
was saying right here
how can we make sense of this new
product well he is saying he agrees that
it's surprising but both panel and led
suppliers confirmed so it is accurate
and he's saying that going from 10
inches to 14 inches is a big jump which
basically implies that he's talking
about the 10.2 inch budget ipad
potentially also having a 14 inch size
and once again he mentions that the 10
inch panel prices in 2022 won't be much
different than 14 inch in 2023 so it
could still be priced low because many
leds would have made it more expensive
and somebody asked ipad air max he said
or just ipad max so it's the budget
model but with a max size display and
why would apple do this well mark
tech1996 on twitter made a good point he
said he wholeheartedly recommends that
apple makes their pro ipads bigger and
gives them a slightly wider aspect ratio
so that stage manager has all the space
it needs and more people are
incentivized to actually use it because
once again stage manager is nice but it
kind of brings the content into the
center of the screen so it'd be nice to
have a larger display however
apple is not giving stage manager to
ipads without the m1 so if apple made a
budget ipad max
it would not get stage manager because
it's not going to get an m1 because the
current rumors are pointed to it getting
an a14 ship not an m1 but hear me out
because i actually have a very very
interesting theory in terms of how apple
is changing up their strategy over the
past couple years and moving forward
well first of all we know that apple's
gonna have their iphone 14 lineup with
both a 14 and a 14 max which is
basically going to be the same specs
just a larger display then we have the
rumors of the 13 inch and 15 inch
macbook air which basically same specs
again but with a larger display size we
have the 14 pro and the 14 pro max same
story then we have the 14 and 16 inch
macbook pro same exact specs but with
larger display higher price so what if
apple is planning to have a budget ipad
and then a 14 inch budget ipad you got
the same specs no difference just the
larger display larger battery it
actually follows up and matches to what
apple is doing with their current
product lineups so after analyzing all
that information from ross young and
everything else with all my research
i've come up with a third scenario that
i think could potentially happen with a
new apple lineup strategy with apple
giving us a 10.9 inch ipad air and 14.1
inch ipad air max you basically just
have the larger display size for a
larger price now i don't know if they're
actually going to call it max they could
just call it the 14 inch ipad air but it
actually makes more sense for the ipad
air than it does for the budget ipad
because the ipad air is going to have
either an m1 or an m2 chip so it's going
to support stage manager which means the
larger 14 inch display is going to make
use of that new stage manager feature so
it totally makes more sense for an ipad
air than it does for a budget ipad in my
opinion and what makes it even better
for apple is that because it has a
massive 14 inch display you can't really
use it in your hands so you need a
keyboard case and of course apple is
working on a next generation magic
keyboard which would come in a new 14
inch size to support that because you
need to support all that weight and
apple could literally charge
i don't know 400 450 dollars for that
huge magic keyboard with new features i
can totally see them doing that and
making a lot of money so here's my
theory on the actual pricing and why it
makes so much sense what if this is
going to be a 14 inch ipad air max they
could give it the same m1 chip again
because the ipad pro is going to have
the m2 so they're going to make it feel
a little bit more exclusive while
sticking to the m1 it's going to have
the same specs and features as the
current ipad air 5 with the m1 just a
larger display for
750 dollars which is exactly in the
middle between the ipad air 5 for 600
and the ipad pro for potentially 900
which i think they're gonna increase the
price to 900 it's gonna slot in
perfectly right there just filling in
that pricing gap with apple's ipad
lineup and their strategy and making it
even better i think apple could
potentially have a spring event in 2023
where they show off this new 14-inch
ipad max potentially alongside a new
15-inch m2 macbook air which also has
the same specs but a larger display and
i know some people were saying that it
doesn't make sense for this new 14-inch
to not be an ipad pro but once again
ross young said hey no mini led no
promotion which confirms it's not going
to be an ipad pro so why would apple
make a larger ipad that's not a pro that
is larger than the 12.9 inch ipad pro
well it's going to allow people to get a
larger display for a smaller price of
course they're going to be sacrificing
features like those display features and
that's going to be really nice for a lot
of people and i think that this 14 inch
size is eventually going to be showing
up in the ipad pro lineup in the future
so they are going to make that bigger as
well but for now a 750 dollar 14 inch m1
ipad air i think fits perfectly into the
lineup so with that said hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you completely
disagree comment down below or subscribe
up above if you liked it definitely
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]